qu'est ce qu'on a fait depuis 15 mois on
a pris un engagement inédit et aucun
autre pays au monde au monde qu'il fait
on va fermer toutes les centrales à
charbon dans ce quinquennat je dis pas
dans quinze ou vingt ans dans ce
quinquennat
ce qui pour les émissions est un combat
essentiel tout sera fait avant la fin
deuxième point on octroie plus de
nouveaux permis d'hydrocarbures
d'exploitation là aussi on est quasiment
l'un des seuls alors qu'on a sur plein
de nos côtes des opportunités et on est
tous en extinction à horizon 2040
troisième point on augmente le prix du
diesel rend du coup les choses plus cher
ce qui est impopulaire s'est
progressivement une transition et puis
on a une prime à la conversion pour que
les françaises et les français achètent
des voitures beaucoup moins polluante
donc les choses sont en train de se
faire la patience je la comprends elle
est là mais l'écologie politique elle se
fait pas du jour au lendemain on doit
contrarier des décennies de choix
industriels d'habitude
moi j'ai pris des engagements clairs je
les tiendrai j'ai beaucoup de défauts
mais vous me connaissez il ya une chose
quand je dis quelque chose je le fais et
après il faut bien voir ce qu'ils disent
'vous devriez faire plus ils sont pas là
quand il faut aller expliquer qu'on va
fermer une centrale à charbon
ils sont pas là pour aider le
gouvernement quand on fait 80 km heure
ou qu'on augmente le prix du diesel ça
vous rend impopulaire la transition
écologique et donc tout le monde est
d'accord avec le principe mais personne
n'est prêt à porter les décisions au
concret moi j'ai un gouvernement qu'il
fait vous avez un président qu'il fait
et on va continuer donc on a eu des
mauvais résultats en 2016 et 2017 en
termes d'émissions ces mauvais résultats
ils n'ont rien à voir avec la politique
qui est mise en place depuis que je suis
élu puisque j'ai été élu en mai 2010 est
le plan climat il est annoncé à
l'automne 2017 et les premières lois
elles ont commencé à s'appliquer en
janvier 2018 mais on ne doit rien lâcher
on doit intensifier et ça fait partie de
la transformation notre industrie de la
transformation notre agriculture vous
avez vu les engagements que j'ai pris
sur le glyphosate et beaucoup d'autres
sujets c'est indispensable